[Music]
well good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight last night a secretly
recorded conversation between President
Trump and his now estranged attorney
Michael Cohen aired on television much
of the dialogue in the tape was garbled
but the thrust seemed to be that one of
the men on the call had a personal
history consistent with what you might
expect from a longtime Atlantic City
casino owner consorting with loose women
was a main theme of the conversation
well for viewers who had until recently
assumed that Donald Trump was a
conventional Midwestern evangelical this
must have been a total shock for
everyone else those of us who've read
the New York Post every day for the past
35 years it was not but for the
professional hysterics in cable land the
Cohen tape was the breaking aspossible
breaking news a stop the presses
Hindenburg a flame moment it was
unbelievable here's a brief selection of
the pandemonium from last night watch go
back now with our breaking news it's a
sin and exclusive the secret recording
between then candidate Donald Trump and
his attorney Michael Cohen Michael
Cohen's lawyer Lanny Davis released a
recording tonight breaking news CNN has
exclusively obtained a secret audio
recording all right the president is
firing back at that audio recording the
breaking news were covering tonight the
Cohen Trump audio recording Donald Trump
Donald Trump Donald Trump 500 years
after Galileo the universe has once
again been reordered this time by the
American news media Donald Trump sits at
the center of it everything is about
Trump every word he utters is
existentially appalling every statement
he makes is the single greatest moral
outrage since the tuskegee syphilis
experiments in the eyes of Washington
Donald Trump is pure badness
unadulterated
200-proof evil and this has effects
because they believe Trump is utterly
entirely bad the left no longer feels
the need to acknowledge nuance of any
kind or practice restraint just a few
years ago they might have called him a
crappy president today they tell us he's
a fascist dictator like Mussolini but of
course much worse than Mussolini because
he's not Mussolini he's Donald Trump I
believe we're in a lot of trouble here
that I've never seen
before in my lifetime of any president
and I would like Obama to speak some out
against it what he wants to do is set
working people against working people
black working people against white
working people a president is not a
monarch or a dictator notwithstanding
the fact that Donald Trump often fancies
himself in that fashion that is exactly
what you see in authoritarian regimes so
what happens if you keep talking like
this every day for a year and a half
well some people will take you seriously
they believe you when they say their
country is becoming a dictatorship and
they get angry some of them will become
violent at least one might shoot a
pucking rational baseball game and who
knows what might happen next
meanwhile Democratic leaders stand back
and watch all of this mostly hoping the
mob doesn't turn on them as ultimately
it will